brothers and sisters and dear friends do
you want Palestine to be free do you
want Justice to Prevail do you guys want
to rebuild Gaza and do you want to feed
those people in Gaza I do and I know you
do brothers and sisters I have come
together with a charity who is inshallah
getting involved in building a w what is
an W brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing deed that you want to do
but we turn it into a moneymaking
machine how the wak is exactly that they
take your money and the money that we
are going to put in in this W this
building and everything everything that
is generated is going to go towards
advocacy it's going to go towards insh
Palestine it's going to go towards
feeding those people who are in need and
rebuilding Gaza imagine you have a
building that is bought and Cann not be
sold and it is only to serve the people
in Gaza and Palestine our Palestinian
brothers and sisters and every single
penny that's made through the rent goes
straight to what to the people in
Palestine and to all these four
different categories of aiding and
helping our Palestinian brothers and
sisters in different ways to free
Palestine inshallah when that day comes
brothers and sisters invest in this W
now and let your charity be a true form
of sakar that is going to carry on and
not a one of donation that you give and
it goes to the place of need but rather
investing it's like you're getting a
share of this property and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
brothers and sisters this is something
that stable and this is something
the done when he bought that well from
that Jewish man to serve the Muslims we
want to do the same thing brothers and
sisters please donate now and share this
message that we can have a w that will
be generating income for our Palestinian
brothers and sisters for the next
hundreds of years and this will be a
form of
true may Allah bless the ones who came
up with this idea I am fully on board
and I myself will'll be donating for
that inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana T bless and
Reserve you guys we will together
inshallah see the day when Palestine
will be
free